salut vous l'avez compris aujourd'hui
nous allons parler de six grands
mystères qui n'ont pas encore été
résolus alors il ya certains mystères
qui sont scientifiques d'autres qui sent
d histoire troublante voix des grands
mystères genre comme pourquoi les
lumières et le clignote là alors
peut-être des mystères un peu plus haut
de gan
si ça te dérange pas c'est un mystère
pour toi et c'est un mystère depuis pas
longtemps
là on va parler de grand mystère depuis
beaucoup plus longtemps en tout cas des
grands mystères qui retourne le cerveau
loïc génériques
mais
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans des
conditions un peu particulières parce
que j'enregistre cette vidéo dans un
théâtre sur la scène d'un théâtre en
live devant 500 personnes qui ne sont
pas dans le théâtre parce qu'elles sont
en fait connectés via un lien c'est une
diffusion en streaming et moi j'ai 20 de
ces personnes là qui sont dans les
écrans qui a derrière moi avec devant
moi pour discuter avec eux réagir et
tout c'est un nouveau concept c'est avec
l'apollo théâtre qu'on fait ça et je
n'ai pas encore tourné mais je sens que
je vais qui fait
[Musique]
voici pourquoi j'ai une feuille dans les
mains parce que j'ai toutes mes notes
parce que comme on est sûr sur le
théâtre comme je vous ai expliqué en
début de vidéo dans l'intro il va
falloir que je j'ai des références aux
textes au fur à mesure
parce que oui mes vidéos sont souvent
multi coupé nous sommes le 24 novembre
nous sommes dans un avion et dans cet
avion il y a une personne qui est assise
à sa place à sa place et qui fume une
cigarette
ok et là vous dites c'est pas bien mais
moi je vous rappelle qu'en 1971 on peut
encore fumer des clopes dans l'avion
donc jusque là tout est normal
on est sur un tout petit vol le vol 305
d'un art northwest airlines qui part de
parkland et qui va à seattle donc c'est
un vol de trente minutes
donc c'est un vol très courts et le mec
qui est assis en train de fumer une
cigarette il a commandé un truc à boire
il appelle une hôtesse et y glisse un
petit papier dans sa poche et lui dit
lisez ce papier s'il vous plaît et elle
allie le papier et de suez à marquer
j'ai une bombe avec moi voilà du coup de
nouveau à 200 mille dollars
jusque là tout est normal que c'est le
sait le pire coup de pression tu sais tu
mets un petit papier de 5000 $ à
l'époque ça ça vaut à peu près un
million de dollars aujourd'hui en termes
de valeur tu vois c'est quand même
beaucoup
donnez-moi également qu'être parachute
et quand on arrive à seattle il faut que
immédiatement vous fassiez le plein de
kérosène
du coup l'hôtesse elle se dit je t'en
parler au commandant de bord mais avant
de faire ça lui ils exigent qu'elle lui
rende le papier et c'est un élément qui
a son importance parce que ça veut dire
jamais en dehors du témoignage de
l'hôtesse on ne sera vraiment ce qui
avait marqué sur ce papier
mine de rien l avant en parler aux
pilotes le pilote se dit écoute ça tombe
bien je suis gendarme sur mes heures
perdues je m'appelle bâtisse a du coup
je vais les appeler au sol n'y a pas de
problème ça c'est vraiment une private
joke parce que cette vidéo n'a aucun
rapport avec la précédente d'un gardien
très bien je vais les appeler acer est à
terre
en lui indiquant fait le chef de chez
paco a indiqué au quai ans répond à ces
exigences il ya pas de problème l'avion
arrive à seattle il faut se dire que
jusqu'à ce moment-là lui il c'est le mec
qui fument dans l'avion on va répondre à
ses exigences
mais il ya personne de l'avion qui est
au courant de ce qui est en train de se
passer
il ya un côté tu vois un peu arsène
lupin de personnes est au courant il n'y
a pas de panique c'est arrivé à seattle
les gens sont bloqués dans l'avion et on
lui amène ce qu'il a demandé donc le
pognon qui a été emmené par des
personnes qui travaillent sur la
compagnie les quatre parachute hockey et
on fait le plein de l'avion et quand ils
voient que l'avion a le plein qui est
qui qui est quasiment terminée il fait
descendre de l'avion
enfin il autorise en tout cas ce qu'on
débarque tous les passagers dont il
reste plus que le personnel est là au
personnel de bord est dit voilà ce qu'on
va faire maintenant parce qu'attention
j'ai une bombe on n'est toujours pas sûr
je vous rappelle qu'il est une bombe
mine de rien attention on va re décoller
et vous allez partir en direction du
mexique
on fera une pause à reno dans le nevada
pour pour faire un ravitaillement mais
on va direction le mexique les gars
elise
ok c'est lui le chef ils partent au
mexique alors ils partent pas tout seul
il ya deux avions de chasse qui sont
envoyées et qui encadre l'avion durant
toute la durée du vol pour surveiller un
petit peu ce qui se passe il arrive à
reno dans le nevada dispose et c'est en
se posant qu'ils se rendent compte
qu'ils avaient pu le mec dans l'avion il
ya plus de trace de l'argent il n'y a
plus de traces des parachutes
donc ils vont voir les mecs de l'avion
de chasse des deuxièmes en chasse ils
disent vous avez vu quelque chose il est
bien le nom d eau en fait j'ai ils ont
rien vu personne l'a vu partir en rien
et on ne retrouve pas ce mec
on ne retrouve pas l'argent fossard que
cet argent c'est qu'il n'a pas été
dépensé parce qu'ils l'ont traqué avec
les numéros 2
deux banques en fait pour essayer de
faire le suivi de la numéro de série qui
assure s'appuyer et il n'a pas été
dépensé le seul truc qu'on sait c'est
que neuf ans après en 1981 il ya un
enfant qui en vacances dans l'orégon
avec ses parents il est en train de
faire un pique nique et il trouve au
bord du fleuve des billets empaqueter il
ya par 6000 $ et ce sont des billets qui
font partie des 200 milles on le sait
parce que justement on a vu avec les
numéros de syrie on sait pas comment ils
ont atterri là rien on n'en sait rien du
tout y'a un portrait robot a été fait
par le fbi en 1972 qui ressemble à ça
n'attendez pas d'image c'est pour le
montage de la vidéo ça c'est pour lui de
nous regarder mais il ressemble à quoi
apparemment il ressemble la nato c'est
assad ce mois ci videmment que dan
cooper sur elle sera probablement un
pseudo c'est ce qu'on sait où ce qu'on
se doute c'est qu'il ya un escalier à
l'arrière de ses boeing la dépouille 727
ya un escalier derrière qui peut
s'ouvrir et se fermer
donc assez logiquement il aurait sauté à
ce moment là mais c'est quand même assez
étrange qu'on l'ait pas vu pourquoi 4
parachute comment il a fait à quel
endroit précis il ya eu plein
d'hypothèses ils ont commencé à faire
les recherches petit fun fact depuis cet
événement il ya un truc qui s'appelle la
vanne cooper sur les boeing 727 qui
empêche l'ouverture de l'escalier
arrière en vol depuis 2016 le fbi haye a
clairement arrêté de faire une enquête
là-dessus parce que ils ont aucune piste
il ne trouve rien
mon
les autres à boucau c'est un mec il est
millionnaire au mexique et durant la
crise de 29
il se dit attention il ya la grosse
crise la grande dépression aux états
unis je vais fondre tout ce que j'ai en
or et en bijoux que je peux acheter etc
et je veux en faire des lingots parce
que c'est sûr que l'or va monter en tant
que valeur refuge et je vais me faire
des cojones en or et donc ils font tout
ça il fait 16 tonnes de lingots cesser
ces parias 1,6 tonnes de lingots d'or tu
vois un peu le délire quoi un lingot
aujourd'hui je crois que ça se revend
dans les trente ou quarante mille
dollars
alain go via lagos a fait pas une tonne
ça fait je ne sais pas donc je vais pas
le dire
voilà ça fait pas très lourd par rapport
à une tonne et en fait ils avaient
raison parce que ça ça prend une valeur
énorme
sauf qu'il peut pas leur vendre parce
qu'en 1934 il ya un un acte qui est
sorti qui interdit que l'or soit une
propriété privée
ok donc il peut par vendre cet or là
donc il attend un petit peu sauf que
juste après que l'acte interdisant de
vendre est sorti tous les amis qui
savait où était caché cet or est ce
qu'il faut quand même savoir qu'il a
embauché un pilote d'avion et avec ses
amis sont allés enterrée lors on sait
pas trop ils sont morts mystérieusement
sauf que lui aussi après il est mort et
que depuis il ya 16 tonnes d'or on sait
pas où c est vraiment depuis 1934
c'est vraiment la fin de mon histoire
n'y a pas plus de rugby on sait qu'il ya
16 tonnes dehors qui traîne quelque part
moi ça me rend ouf
donc à partir de demain si vous croisez
au mexique avec un détecteur comme ça
mon
troisième lyster la matière de l'univers
donc là c'est un mystère un peu plus
scientifique mais hyper intéressant
depuis quelques décennies on commence à
savoir de quoi est composé l'univers des
cosmologistes ils ont découvert deux
choses les cosmologistes ils ont
découvert que la matière noire et
l'énergie noire c'est ce qui composait
le plus l'univers qui nous entoure donc
les étoiles les galaxies sont composés
de ces deux éléments la matière noire et
énergie noire mais la matière noire
ça représente 27% de l'univers c'est
quand même beaucoup 27%
on ne peut pas la détecter on a pu la
déduire par rapport à l'impact qu'elle a
sur la matière visible parce que on
pense que la masse est à peu près six
fois plus élevé que la matière visible
cette matière noire qu'on ne peut pas
voir on peut pas la détecter on peut pas
vraiment la quantifier
on a juste déduit c'était 27 % des
livres à côté de ça on a pu déduire que
l'univers sera composé à 68 % d'énergie
noire s'est beaucoup se sentent 8%
sachant que l'énergie noire on peut pas
la voir on peut pas la détecter on ne
peut que la déduire en fait l'univers
pour que vous compreniez l'univers dans
son ensemble il est composé d'amas de
galaxies un peu tentaculaire et le reste
c'est du vide et ce vide ils
représentent 90% de l'univers ok donc la
matière visible et toute l'énergie
visible c'est 10% l'univers et en vrai
si même 5% l'univers parce qu'il ya du
vide aussi dans la matière visible et
dans les amas de galaxies
ça veut dire que 95 % de l'univers est
composé de trucs qu'on ne sait pas voir
qu'on ne sait pas détecté qu'on ne sait
pas comprendre qu'on ne sait pas déduire
la composition qu'on ne sait pas à quoi
ça sert et que nous on a un train de se
batailler a commencé à comprendre 5% à
peine de l'univers et je trouve ça assez
fou pour le mettre dans la catégorie des
grands mystères non résolus
parce que comme on avance beaucoup
scientifiquement ces dernières années
dans la connaissance et tout c'est
vraiment un des zooms qui dit
frère tu sais rien du tout en fait
mystères non résolus
je vous renvoie sûrement dans la
description je mettrai une vidéo
d'aurélien barreau aussi qui en parle de
manière passionnée et passionnante et
c'est juste fou ça nous ramène à notre
place et après quand tu roules zoom sur
la planète tu dis bon on ferait mieux de
comprendre un petit peu ce qu'on est en
train de faire nous les humains sur sur
notre échelle planétaire et prendre soin
de strueth ici particulier plutôt que de
chercher à essayer de d'avoir un max de
connaissances mais pas de s'en servir
dans le réel
c'était mon message engagé mais ça se
passe le 22 novembre 1987 au nord de la
rochelle un enfant découvre un playmobil
en forme d'éléphant qui va dans un
cirque
il a 50 et c'est moi et ça n'a rien à
voir avec l'histoire mais c'est vrai
techniquement c'est si c'est assez 22
devant 1987 ok mais c'est ici c'est
l'éléphant dit si c'était ou d'avoir ce
à quoi respecter un peu le 22 novembre
1987 il se passe autre chose quand yaya
deux stations de télévision à chicago
qui sont en train de diffuser un épisode
de doctor who et il va subir deux
coupures
durant cet épisode c'est à dire que
vraiment le cpie raté et toutes les
télés qui capte ses antennes là ils ont
la pire vidéo du monde qui apparaît
c'est à dire celle ci
[Musique]
c'est free qui trouve ça fait flipper
laisse tomber et dites vous qu on est en
87 on n'a pas vraiment l'habitude que ce
genre de choses soient possibles sert à
rien c'est un [ __ ] de crack
technologie kth le gars qui a fait ça
moi les gars qui ont fait ça parce qu'on
s'est aperçu quand même qu'ils étaient
de aussi dont ils ont une coupure de 25
secondes une de 90 secondes
et quand la vidéo fait son apparition on
voit une personne qui partent le masque
de match max est drôle c'est une série
d'accès drôme où on est dans un monde où
il distribue dans ce monde-là
gratuitement des postes de télévision à
tout le monde et il ya une loi qui a
perdi d'éteindre la télé les gens sont
obligés de regarder ça et max headroom
c'est un présentateur télé ou un
journaliste dans l'émission et à la
suite d'un accident il a un avatar
virtuel qui se crée et à eux deux ils
vont essayer de faire tomber ce système
tyrannique
donc on peut dire que max headroom et
son avatar était contre la
lobotomisation merci j'allais le dire
mais tu modeler modja bouge évidemment
de la télévision sur le grand public
après je suis pas sûr que le message il
soit bien passé parce que la deuxième
vidéo celles qui durent 90 secondes
il est juste en train de se faire fesser
par quelqu'un
ont compris le message
mais le fait tic par contre c'est un peu
fou les deux personnes n'ont jamais
étant identifiés et on n'a pas vraiment
compris comment il avait réussi à
pirater ça c'est un mystère non résolus
[Musique]
1978 thomass malthus c'est un économiste
qui a calculé une prédiction de la
thématique entre la population existante
sur la planète et le volume de
production nécessaires à maintenir en
vie
cette population il a fait des outils il
a créé un outil assez cohérent pour lui
sa conclusion elle est sympa le coup
paraît logique mais elle est simple si
le premier en fait à parler
d'effondrement dans un certain sens il
dit qu'il n'y a que trois fins possibles
à une population par rapport au volume
de production possibles faisant revivre
cette population c'est la famine la
guerre où l'effondrement parce qu'il n'y
a plus assez de ressources et ça peut
créer des maladies parce qu'on a abîmé
l'environnement pour lui il ya que deux
solutions soit la population augmente de
manière exponentielle
un peu comme pour dans l'échiquier de 6
à sinon la population augmenterait de
manière linéaire donc là c'est juste en
un crémant toujours un chiffre donc ces
2 4 6 8 10 12 14 16 18 cents par exemple
experts mais quoi qu'il arrive les
ressources elles augmentent de manière
linéaire on le sait aujourd'hui et la
population augmente de manière
exponentielle et même si on a créé
mandat gros chiffres dans le linéaire de
la production des ressources
l'exponentielle le rattrape toujours et
un moment donné on s'est toujours à voir
et on ne peut plus manger
du coup le grands mystères non résolus
sait comment ça se fait que depuis deux
cents ans la population allaient été
multipliés alors x 6 et qui vu aucun
enfant dormant donc ça pour quoi
faut vraiment se poser les bonnes
questions voilà réponse je voulais dire
il ya un spoil
c'est qu'on a [ __ ] la planète tullow
oil pour apprendre l'art et la deuxième
question t1 mystères non résolus et qui
risquent de se résoudre malgré nous
c'est que quand est ce que va arriver
l'effondrement et lequel des trois ce
sera voilà là on vient de vivre un truc
pas cool
à cause d'un pan colin mais bon c'est
surtout à cause de l'être humain au
départ si ce qui a causé sa et je me
disais bien c'était d'autant plus cool
d'en parler dans cette vidéo des
mystères non résolus se dire c'est assez
mystérieux qu'on soit encore debout
peut-être on pourrait en profiter pour
le rester voilà c'était le deuxième
message engagé
[Musique]
donc l'homme au masque de fer c'est
sûrement le prisonnier le plus connu de
france
évidemment il a été enfermé à la
bastille et à l'époque il ya un truc
qu'on sait pas quand même parce qu'il ya
plein de fantasmes sur l'homme au masque
de fer sur le fait qu'il avait un masque
mais à l'époque c'était assez courant de
mettre un loup quelque chose pour le
cacher le visage des personnes qui
étaient prisionniers surtout quand
c'était des prisonniers qu'ils
détenaient des savoirs un petit peu
d'états des secrets d'état
on voulait pas qu'on sache qui s'est
donc s'étaient cachés comme ça après il
ya eu des recherches qui ont été faites
on s'est aperçu aussi et même les
scientifiques sont d'accord avec ça
qu'ils ne pouvaient pas avoir son masque
en permanence c'est impossible parce
qu'on sait que le masque qui lui
permettait d'ouvrir la bouche et de
manger en gardant le masque et on savait
qu'ils avaient interdiction de l'enlever
sinon ils étaient tués
mais on sait aussi que s'il avait gardé
son masque en permanence il serait
clairement mort de septicémie il aurait
maladie du genre là donc on pense qu'il
avait son masque dès qu'il était en
public sur des transferts par exemple ou
quand ils allaient à la messe parce
qu'on le l'autoriser à aller à la messe
ou transférés à des endroits où à
d'autres et de masques servait à ça on
sait aussi que c'est quelqu'un qui a été
extrêmement bien traités le mec avait le
droit de recevoir des musiciens pour
écouter de la musique dans sa prison on
sait aussi qu'il adorait les beaux
tissus et que du coup ils avaient des
bras des draps et des beaux tissus qui
coûtait un petit peu cher il avait même
le droit d'avoir de la dentelle dans sa
cellule dont il ya un truc de attendre
c'est qui ce mec comment ça se fait ce
bail qu'ils aient droit plein de trous
comme ça alors il ya plein d'hypothèses
dessus mais le mystère et non résolus
aujourd'hui on sait qu'il a été fermée
enfermé sous louis xiv on sait que c'est
louis 15 qui est le dernier qui a su qui
s'était il y en a qui pensent que ce
serait le frère jumeau de louis xiv et
donc c'était pour l'empêcher d'accéder
au trône bien là d'autres qui pensent
que ce serait encore d'autres personnes
mais pareil qui était prétendants
légitimes peut-être au trône mais au
final on sait rien du tout il ya une
autre hypothèse que je connaissais pas
que j'ai découvert en faisant le sac
était intéressant là qui pensent que ce
serait d'artagnan d'artagnan a existé un
d'artagnan ça aurait pu être lui et il
aurait de secret détails ont leur est
enfermé et mis un masque souvent que les
autres parce que on voulait pas que les
autres mousquetaires reconnaissent que
c'était leur leader d'artagnan ça c'est
encore une autre hypothèse crédible si
vous aimez découvrir des choses qui vous
stimule le cerveau font réfléchir ou
juste des connaissances un petit peu fun
je vous invite à lire un extrait de mon
magazine curieuse via un lien dans la
description
c'est un magazine mensuel papier de plus
de 40 pages que vous recevez où que vous
habitiez dans le monde les frais de port
sont inclus l'abonnement est annuelle et
revient à moins de 2 euros 50 par mois
c'est mieux qu'un type i c'est moins
cher qu'un seul sur twitter en plus vous
allez recevoir mon magazine toute
l'année directement dans votre boîte aux
lettres
si vous ne connaissez pas je m'appelle
toujours fabien olicard vous pouvez vous
abonner à cette chaîne c'est gratuit
activer la cloche pour être sûr d'être
notifiés de la prochaine vidéo leakée
cette vidéo ciel vous a plu et si vous
mais deux autres vidéos
celle ci c'est une vidéo sur les
habitudes un peu bizarres des génies et
ça cette vidéo sur une semaine un peu
folle qui m'est arrivé où j'ai terminé
en pleurs dans les toilettes d'un train
voilà à très bientôt ciao